[Musik]
die aktiven orang utans die sich für
alles interessieren es gibt die in sich
gekehrten die viel denken und wenig
interagieren und von daher gibt es nicht
die typische das typische charakter will
dann sind extrem individuell genau wie
gegeben
[Musik]
jetzt einfach drin das ist so wird
ausprobiert und am anfang sind relativ
viele fehler dabei es dauert auch eine
ganze zeit dass sie rauskriegen dass die
sicherste verbindung zwischen bäumen
oben im grunde die alternativ stadt
gehört auf meinen kleinen morgen
hochzuklettern sich festzuhalten und
anfangen zu schwingen aber das klappt
nicht weil der baum nicht lang genug ist
oder die schwimmdistanz nicht groß genug
ist muss mal verbinden kann
es dauert einfach
[Musik]
ebenso werden orang utans über 60 jahre
alt in der wildbahn ist im durchschnitt
nur 30 bis 35 jahren
orangen gehören zur familie der
menschenaffen sind die einzigen
menschenaffen die weitestgehend solitär
leben und daher ganz andere
sozialstruktur als gorillas bonobos und
schimpansen und als einzige ja ganz
anders angepasst sind die einzigen im
grunde nach lebenden menschen affen und
dazu brauchen eine sehr spezifische
intelligentes um sich in diesem raum
zeit gefüge zu recht zu finden das ist
unglaublich verziehen
[Musik]
die erhaltung der art hängt davon ab wie
erfolgreich der zuschuss in zukunft sein
von den 6000 oder mutter die noch in der
wildbahn hier in sumatra vorkommen sind
wahrscheinlich nur 1600 in
schutzgebieten davon wird in der zukunft
abhängen wie gut diese schutzgebiete
installiert sind und das wird den
ausschlag geben ob der orang utan auch
im nächsten jahrtausend noch lebt oder
ob die art aus sternen